ce
ces ruines sont tout ce qui reste de la
ville de borodianka à 70 kilomètres au
nord de kiev maintenant que les troupes
russes se sont retirés ce sont désormais
les pompiers et les démineurs qui sont à
pied d'oeuvre pour tenter de sécuriser
la ville on estime ici que les cadavres
vont se compter par centaines ne serait
ce que dans les immeubles que vous voyez
derrière moi ces derniers jours 22 corps
ont été retrouvés
notre méfiance
en ce moment nous essayons de retirer
les parties les plus instables de ces
immeubles pour assurer notre propre
sécurité
digne et travaille à sa mère
nous déblayons aussi les débris et nous
vérifions s'il ya des corps coincés de
soutien
[Musique]
il va falloir beaucoup de temps pour que
cette ville soit habitable beaucoup de
temps pour que les besoins de première
nécessité soient restaurées mais malgré
des conditions de vie extrêmement
difficiles certains habitants continuent
de vivre à vos revient qu'à certains
même ont refusé de quitter la ville
alors que les combats faisaient rage
ils ont bombardé les maisons des gens
les écoles tout il n'y avait aucun
soldat ukrainien ici ils ont juste
bombarder des civils je n'imagine pas la
vie revenir ici quand je rentre à la
maison je marche sans but qu'est-ce que
je peux faire d'autre
c'est sûr on va gagner nous allons
reconstruire notre pays il sera encore
meilleur mais une telle tragédie tous
ces gens fuient les gens pacifiques qui
sont ben gourion
ses paysages de désolation ne sont
qu'une infime partie de ce qu'on peut
observer dans les localités au nord de
kiev désormais vladimir poutine
concentre ses troupes dans l'est du pays
et dans la région du donbass on s'attend
là-bas à des destructions beaucoup plus
importante et un nombre de victimes
beaucoup plus élevé